my name is alex i work in visma
before i get into the topic i'd like to
get a sense of the audience so i'm
curious
raise your hand if you work in an
organization with fewer than 50
employees
okay so a minority
raise your hand if you think that your
organization is
pretty good at security in general
okay also a minority interesting
and so the premise of this talk as you
probably have gathered is that the
security posture of small software
companies
is pretty bad
and in the first part of the talk i'll
explain why i think that's the case
what the common challenges uh i think
are um
and how
they can be addressed if you are in this
danger zone as i call it um and you
don't really have a security program as
a small software company today
and the final part i'll go talk a bit
about
our experience in visma with different
security testing tools and our
experience with our bug bounty programs
as well
so let's get started
um visma is a software company um but we
have a group of software companies so
there's about 200 companies that
are part of isma we're mostly in the
nordics and in europe also some in latin
america
and as you might imagine this means that
the scalability of our products is
important but also the scalability of
the organization is important because we
acquire a new company about once a week
now how do we learn about security
posture of other companies
one channel is
through technical due diligence that we
do in visma before we potentially buy a
company right then if we buy 50
companies a year that means we do at
least
well more than 50 technical due
diligences a year and security is quite
an important part of what we evaluate
when we look at
companies
another channel of course is vendors as
any software company we also buy a lot
of software and we do security risk
assessments of the vendors and of the
products
so that's another way we learn about
security of other companies
then we have
some customers and partners that we have
a
more tight relationship with than others
and in some cases we use our security
competence and capabilities to help
a particular customer or partner
with
you know strengthening their security
posture so that's another way that we
learn
now in this one i think we are pretty
lucky because we are a big company we
have a lot of incentives and pressures
on us
that makes it kind of easy for us to
invest in security
for instance we have
a lot of customers and some of them are
very professional right they know what
to
ask of us to demand from us
and they help hold our feet to the fire
as a software vendor
to
continue our growth we also need to be
able to attract and retain employees
right if we don't have good people in
the company we can't do anything
so
you know having security
as a strength being known for security
our security competence or capabilities
um
has a positive impact while if we were
known as a company that treated employee
or customer data
in an irresponsible way or if we were
known as an unethical company i think we
would struggle you know even more than
most companies are struggling to get
talent today
we have all professional owners and
investors as well
right our board our investors they
demand from us and they support that we
invest money
time other resources into security
and finally since we are in 35 plus
countries
a lot of governmental and
non-governmental organizations are kind
of paying attention to what we do right
if we
step
wrong then that is likely to to have a
significant significant attention
so all of these things makes it easy for
us to
invest and take security seriously
but how many of these incentives and
pressures are true for
a small software company
maybe
one or maybe zero
um and
i think that's that explains why
we see that
small software companies
very often have very bad security
often irresponsible
um and the danger zone i have defined
here is less than 30 employees less than
5 million euros in revenue
i think it's
because of many reasons but i think the
systematic reasons are a big a big part
of it
and i think
these small companies they have a lot of
other things to think about and care
about security might not be
top of mind
and it might also be
because they think security kind of has
to be expensive
and that's uh one thing i want to kind
of debunk today
so the good news
is that
it doesn't take much to be above average
in this category
right it's
there are some companies that are small
and are doing very well i don't want to
generalize completely
but
if you are in this
danger zone
security is likely to be a very low
priority
um so if you do something
you are already a lot better than many
of your competitors
and in a small company one person can
also have a lot of impact
so if you find yourself in this
situation and you
kind of decide to do something about it
or to drive
security forward in the company you can
do a lot of good
so that's some good news
so the first common
challenge that we see in this month that
i want to talk about
is
well often we ask companies you know who
is responsible for security
at your company in your organization
and most often
we get a confused look back
so it shows that it's not top of mind
it's not very clear
who is responsible
and after some thinking time
i usually get one of three answers
one is well of course it's everyone's
responsibility
or
well of course it's the ceo's
responsibility they're responsible for
everything right
or my favorite
security is handled by our vendor
and what they mean usually when i get
this answer is that
you know their infrastructure is hosted
with some infrastructure vendor and they
have an iso 27
27001 certificate
maybe they have um you know intrusion
detection system in place or something
like that
and the company imagines well okay we
have outsourced
our security so nothing we need to
to think about
and
i think the third answer is clearly a
really bad one right i think everyone
can see that but what about the two the
two first ones they're kind of right i
think
but what usually happens is that
the companies cannot explain how does
that translate
into
um
how is the responsibility distributed in
the organization from you know if it is
in one person or if it is
distributed across everyone how does
that translate into security
considerations
being taken into account in the
company's day-to-day activities
so what i think uh you know the answer
we are looking for here or if you are at
a small company what
you know at least i think a good step
would be is to on the one hand yes make
sure that
responsibility for security is very
clearly
assigned
whether it's a dedicated role or not
but then
you know think about and plan how does
that responsibility how is that
distributed to the rest of the
organization what kind of what does it
mean for different
processes how is security then being
taken into account into all the
company's activities
another common problem
with these small software companies is
that
many of them don't have any security
competence because they don't they
haven't recruited for it
um
and then whether they have security
competence or not in the organization at
all
is a function of how lucky they have
been during their uh recruitment
so my advice here would be to do start
with a competence mapping right figure
out
who knows something about what
i can understand that a small software
company cannot
have many dedicated people you know in
full-time roles dedicated to security
but at least you should make sure that
there are a number of people with
some security competence motivation
engagement and as we talked about
responsibility and if you do this
competence mapping and you see security
doesn't really come up
well then you know what you need to hire
for in the next recruitment process
a related problem here that i also see a
lot is that
and this sometimes also goes for for
large companies that they kind of expect
or maybe hope
that developers and others
stay up to date and develop their
competence on their own and a lot of us
like to do that
but the company of course i think has a
responsibility to support
and encourage that
right so supporting
financially you know buying books or
courses or certifications or whatever
people are actually
engaged by and motivated by to help
increase competence
but again it doesn't have to be
expensive stuff right you don't have to
go to some
black cat course for five days that
costs i don't know ten thousand dollars
or whatever
um a simple thing that any company could
do is to have these regular brown bag
sessions
right once a week or once a month assign
responsibility to someone
they prepared
by doing some research on some
particular security threat for instance
maybe they then in a meeting in 30
minutes or 60 minutes
they can then share
okay what did i learn you know what is
the security threat how do you mitigate
it maybe they share some news articles
uh what was the impact to other
companies like us
when the vulnerability was exploited
and when you have done that 6 12 18
times
that already helps increase security
competence in the organization and it
kind of nudges the security culture as
well
of course if you want to be more
hands-on you can not just have someone
talking about it but you could
organize
some event where people are can get
hands-on
attack a vulnerable system
obviously the knowledge is much more
likely to be retained in these cases
you could use os security shepard for
this for instance a
free tool
in this mode we also have secure code
warrior i saw them right outside
actually
um this is a
tool that
allows a developer to log into a web
based portal they pick the technologies
that they're interested in
well that they know that they want to be
better at when it comes to security
then they are presented with a lot of
gamified
tasks right
here
they need to identify what snippet of
code is actually vulnerable
and then the next step is to pick which
solution
which code solution actually mitigates
the problem or avoids the security
vulnerability in the first place
um internally in visma we have
tournaments in you know based on this
platform so just a couple of days ago
one of the kind of our first quarter
tournament internally lots of developers
across all these companies uh competed
and we gave out some some swag to the to
the winner
and you also see on the bottom left
there
that it's very engaging
and in general developers really enjoy
this
which
of course makes it
very good
all right
third common problem among small
software companies is lack of threat
awareness
if you ask a small software company
people working there you know which
threats are most relevant to you which
security threats are you concerned about
often you'll get a blank stare in return
so the good news is that there are a lot
of different resources to learn from
right as a small software company you
can ask yourself
are there any threats that we have
been
kind of a victim of before you can use
our experience
you can think about
other
companies
in your market companies similar to you
what kind of threats have they been the
victim of you can connect with other
organizations in the industry
and you can
enumerate all of these threats
right and i also included
some examples here you know this is the
website for the european european union
agency for cyber security they have a
portal with lots of news items that's
constantly updated that's the source to
learn about okay what threats are out
there now should we care about any of
these
norwegian
cyber security authorities they have a
yearly report
in this one they talked about
phishing
brute force attacks reuse of passwords
um
many other things right and that's all
inspiration like if you're actually
starting from zero which many of these
companies are this is one way to to do
it
and then because we all have a budget
you cannot protect against everything
and you won't be able to even if you try
but then prioritize okay
we know about 200 threats but which ones
are most
risky to us as a company which ones do
we actually want to
mitigate against
then
you might end up with something like
this right maybe top five looks like
this
but then you have
the next issue which is that another
many companies might be aware of
security threats but they haven't really
agreed on what to do about them
or if they have agreed
maybe different people have different
opinions
right it's
not that uncommon
to talk to a company and a development
team where
developers are aware of cross-site
scripting and sql injection and all
these things
but people have different ideas about
what the right way to mitigate it is
some people say okay we'll write the
queries in this way
or another person will say well we're
going to use you know this way in our
framework to handle this because it has
some building functionality for it a
third person might have a different idea
so that the team the organization is not
really aligned on how to mitigate the
threat
so
that my advice here is to be explicit
right talk about discuss what is the
best way of mitigating it but then write
it down and make this place it
communicated so that the organization is
actually
aligned on how to do it so people don't
try to
solve the same thing in in many
different ways
because yeah some of those are probably
going to be less effective than others
right
final
um problem that we see a lot is that
companies don't do any security testing
they might have responsibility okay they
might have the competence they might
know the threats they might have ideas
about mitigation
but they don't actually
do any testing
um
also sometimes um i talk to companies
who might be using one security testing
tool and kind of rely on that for
everything
right yes we use sonarcube to look for
vulnerabilities in our software but we
have fixed all the issues so now
we are secure
and of course that's not how it works
um
so again if you're starting from zero
right what you what can you do well
first of all make it easy for people who
discover or learn about security
problems make it easy for them to report
it to you in a in a safe way welcome it
create the responsible disclosure page
on your website um
maybe you want to give away swag or put
their name in a hall of fame if they
report something and it's a actual
vulnerability that you that you fix
um bisma has a responsible disclosure
page i think we've had
more than 500
reports that way just uh through a
responsible disclosure email box
and 300 of them have been verified and
fixed
and
more than 100 people said yes to be on
the on the hall of fame page
right so um not something that takes a
lot of time or money kind of a
hygiene basic hygiene thing that
everyone should do
next thing of course is code scanning
if a small software company is doing
something
on the security testing side this is
most
this is the most frequent thing that
they do
and maybe use on our cube to scan their
source code for vulnerabilities or
some other tool
any development activity is going to
create bugs including security bugs and
using tools to
at least try to pick low hanging fruit
is very very valuable
um
web scanning is another
yeah technique another category of
testing tools
again not very often used by these
smaller software companies
um
these are tools that send http requests
to basically anywhere you point it look
for different types of vulnerabilities
some overlap with static code analysis
but also
it will find it can find other types of
issues
and
what's nice about many of these tools is
that they
are very
or some of them at least are very fire
and forget you can kind of point it to a
url it will monitor and scan
continuously and you can go into the
reports or get notified whenever
something is found
um again not something that has to take
a lot of time or money to actually set
up you can run it in a test environment
or you can run it in production
next is the dependency scanning or
software composition analysis tools that
will identify vulnerable third-party
components
but also
problematic licenses
and again
kind of basic uh things that also small
software companies
can do
if you go to almost.org you can find on
their wiki lists of tools for all of
these categories there are free options
in all categories that work well
and of course there are a bunch of
commercial
options as well
so i thought it might be useful to talk
about
our experiences in vispa with different
tools in this area
so if i start with the static
application security testing or code
scanning
in visma we are mostly using coverity
and polaris at the moment
these are commercial tools from synopsis
coverity is an on-premises solution an
older one polaris is the
newer cloud-based version but i think
it's the same analysis engine behind
both of them and we're kind of halfway
in the migration between these two tools
the quality of the scans and the
findings and so on
are pretty good
with all of these tools of course
there's going to be a lot of false
positives so you always have to
analyze the findings and many of them
will not be real
security threats
but in general we're happy
with these tools
we do notice that maybe there are a bit
gradually starting to lag a bit behind
the tools do feel like they were
developed like a decade ago
but with the findings and the kind of
the security aspect of it
we are pretty happy
how easy is it how easy it is to use
and kind of the developer friendliness
of it
maybe not the top score on that
front
but most teams in visma will run this
scan more or less every day
so that when something is found they can
analyze it triage it
immediately
then we also use vera code this is
another commercial tool but this is the
tool that we use for
the technical due diligences and there's
no
big reason
uh other you know for using a separate
tool for this other than we actually
wanted it to be separate kind of for
privacy and information security reasons
we wanted to
have one
thing for our internal teams and visma
companies and another separate thing for
these technical due diligence
operations but
i would say we have kind of similar
similar opinion on the security findings
of error code and query templates
they both seem
reasonably good
vera code as well is a tool where you
really notice that kind of the ui the
user experience is is not good
um
so that's
yeah one one downside but on the
security side of things which
matters the most especially for this
tool since this is not something all the
teams use right
um it
few people actually interact with this
tool so not a big issue
then we have github advanced security
there was a session on this
before launch which was very good
and we don't have a lot of experience
with github advanced security
but we are piloting it now this is a
paid feature
and i think it includes some static code
analysis
tools
the first kind of
impressions that we have from a few
teams that have tried this out is that
they're very happy with it
very developer centric very easy to use
so this could be
well at least something like this is
definitely the the future and this is
kind of the right direction to go in for
these kinds of tools i think whether it
means we're going to switch um you know
move from
polaris to github advanced security i
don't know but at least we're looking at
it
sonar cube is also used a lot in this
model though
more for code quality things than for
security it's used a bit for security as
well but i don't think um
i don't get the impression that people
want to use solar cube for
security like we have other tools like
pilates and error code which were
specifically created for that
and
i don't think sonar cube is
at the same
level in same maturity in the security
department
so
yeah more used for code quality than
security
in visma
and then finally we have
snek which also is a commercial tool
we use snik a lot in visma but not for
static code analysis i think the static
code analysis part of snake is
newer a bit more
experimental um
but also this is something that we're
looking at and evaluating the developer
experience is really good with nick
so we're very happy with nick in general
but we haven't used the static code
analysis feature of snake a lot so far
then we have dynamic application
security testing or web scanning
here we use detectify this is our
primary web scanning tool and it's a
commercial one and as i mentioned
earlier this is really nice um
convenient to use you can point it to
some url
maybe you help it log in if you need to
and then it can just monitor and
continuously scan that according to
whatever schedule or frequency you want
and you can get notifications or reports
for any type of of findings
so this is also something where
you know
most of our products are just
monitored by this tool
24 7 and when there are findings the
development teams are notified and we'll
look at it is it you know is it real is
it something we should be concerned
about or or not
so in general very happy about about
detectify
burp suite is used a lot in this small
although
this is more for manual exploratory
testing right the
kind of swiss army knife of pen testers
i think we have a professional pen test
team inside of visma they use burp suite
all the time in our development teams
it's not used a lot again because you
kind of need to
like you need to have an idea
about what you're doing what you want to
try to do it kind of
requires
some
yeah security competence to use it
effectively so most development teams
don't use this they rely on all the
other tools i've been talking about
but then they get this pen test report
from the pentas team that uses this
maybe once a year or something like that
there are some teams who choose to use
burp suite typically when a team has a
security engineer that might be some
kind of a bit extra motivated than
interested in
security they might you know try
something explore something
try something out and do some manual ad
hoc exploratory security testing on
their own
but again mostly used by the by the
penthouse team
um
yeah you can do
you can do um a lot
with the free version so if you're just
a developer and a team the free version
might be
um sufficient but of course in the pen
test team they have a paid version with
all the bells and whistles
finally i thought i'd mention oau's app
so this is the
um well this is another free
tool in this category
um
it
can do active scans as well if you point
it somewhere or it can be the proxy and
listen to what's going on and
detect security issues
um not used a lot in visma but some
teams choose to include this in their
build and deployment pipeline
so
i don't think there are
teams that do that for detectify because
it's not a triggered thing right it's a
scheduled thing that just runs on a
schedule
but if they want something
in their build and deployment pipeline
they often choose to
run an active scan in
osap in that way
all right
final category i think
so then we have software composition
analysis
and here the snick is the big deal in
visma
most teams use snick
which looks at manifest files
so it tries to look at the packages that
you have included in your software
through these manifest files through
package managers
you get packages
rubygems whatever it is
and it looks for these yeah what are the
components
are there known vulnerabilities in these
components are you using an old version
and are there any potential license
issues it will report all of that in a
very
nice way
this is a commercial
paid paid tool but very developer
friendly developer centric very easy to
use very effective
so
yeah only good things to say about snek
we are very happy with it
but of course if you have software where
you are including dependencies not as
packages not through manifest files
snick will not identify the dependency
so that's why we also
keep black duck binary analysis around
previously called protocode
and this is used less but this is kind
of the backup when kind of sneak doesn't
work or when snake is insufficient we
use black duck binder analysis because
it can scan
binary data
so if we have some
you know net project that has included
dlls directly instead of a nougat
package
then black duck binder analysis can
identify
um the component that we have included
and tell us whether it's vulnerable or
not or if there's a license issue we
also use it sometimes for
executables
i mentioned earlier that sometimes we do
security and risk assessments of vendors
we can put their software even if we
don't have their source code we can put
their binary their installer whatever
into blackduck binary analysis and get
some interesting findings from there
we have also used it when
we're looking at buying a company that
white labels uh software from another
company
then it's hard for us to know you know
what's the security maturity of that
white playable product but then we can
put the binary binaries in here and we
can get some idea of how all the
components are
what the security level is
so also a commercial tool but
quite useful
easy to use as well
then we have github dependable
we use github and visma and the pandabot
is really awesome so this is kind of
not our primary tool but a lot of teams
kind of use this
and get the benefit just because they're
using
github you know having
automatically created folder requests
that will fix some of these
old dependencies for you is super
convenient
so yeah only good things to say really
about
github and github dependables
then finally we have two more tools and
they are both
free in both senses of the word
open source and don't have to pay to use
them
or wasp dependency check
that supports
primarily
net and java so if you want to
scan your java.net dependencies you can
use this tool
it also has experimental support for a
number of other languages
so you can try it out and see how
effective it is
easy to include in a build or deployment
pipeline if you want to do that
so yeah some teams do that but kind of
not needed because we we rely mostly on
snake but if we did not have snick this
would be a good uh good option
and finally retire.js is kind of the
same but for javascript
um
we used it we used these two
a lot before we had znik uh less so now
but another nice thing with retire.js is
that it exists as a browser extension so
you can install it in your browser and
whenever you're on any website you'll
see all the outdated javascript
components that are used on that website
but it's also a
command line tool so can also be
included in build and deployment
pipelines
then
when a team in visma has used all of
these automated tools
to kind of try to pick away the low
hanging fruit
the final step
um is to onboard to
our bug bounty programs
we currently use the integrity platform
for this
europe based
we use hacker one a couple of years ago
but switched
um i don't know if you can see here uh
we pay from 100 euros to 7 500 euros
for people who i don't if they identify
you know real security vulnerabilities
in our software
um
we have a private program and a public
program so usually
you know we put a team or a visma
company on the private program first you
know there we have
specifically invited hackers a smaller
pool
you know people that we have some
relationship with or have some trust
with
and they kind of get get the chance to
do their thing first you know scan do
recon try all kinds of stuff you know
following the rules of the program of
course
um
and yeah if they find something or when
they report something we look at it if
it's true we we pay out
if they've been if a team or a company
has been on the private program for a
while and kind of the
incoming traffic or the you know the
findings are kind of dying down a bit
it's a bit quiet
then that's a good opportunity to get
them on the public program
where basically anyone
who
has an integrity account can
get access to the program and and
try to find vulnerabilities in the
software
yeah so the private program is uh not
in-house it is um
internal to the integrity platform
so there might be i don't know the
number but whether it's 50 or 300 but
there's a number of people then who kind
of have access to all the
well to the private program and can
try to find stuff on any of the things
that are in scope for that program
yeah so
we've had
this program for
three three plus years i think
we've had 2 700 submissions 98
of them have turned out to be valid
right because these platforms have
reputation systems so that you know if
you just spam things that are not
correct
you'll get punished for that in some way
and we paid out more than five uh 400
000 euros in bounties in over these
years
and
to answer the question yes it is totally
worth it
and we think we would have to i mean
from both sides kind of in a way
you know how one thing to ask is how
many people would we have to
hire to find all of these things
what's the cost of that
probably more
um and the other is okay what is the
cost
if these things were not identified and
something was exploited
in
we have kind of a rule of thumb
in visma that one euro spent on the bug
bounty award
is somewhere between 10 and 100 euros
avoided in in damage
so we certainly think this is worth it
i also included some statistics here
from our different tools
so on the left side you see the
vulnerabilities
that are most often reported by our
static code scanning tools
so this includes false positives and
this is not based on verified
vulnerabilities just what the tooling
reports to us most often
cross-site request forgery cross-site
scripting
insecure cookies version disclosure
okay
now if we take a look at the bug bounty
diagram what are the most commonly
and this is based on verified
vulnerabilities by the way
so what are the most
actual vulnerabilities found
in the bugbounty program well the first
one is insecure direct object references
you know where you have uh
you know look at user id5 or something
right and you see the user but then you
can switch the number to something else
and you get access to it even though you
shouldn't
um very common problem
and the the second one is improper
access control which is kind of similar
right same kind of same type of thing
i think one interesting thing here is
you see how
all the tooling
is kind of finding the low hanging fruit
and bugbounty program you see that's for
the type of vulnerabilities that you
cannot really
find
with the tools right eye doors and
improper access control
is hard to impossible to find with the
tools right so that also is aligned with
how we kind of use the tooling first and
then bug bound is kind of the final
thing you do when you think you have
everything under control
and typically then the bug boundary
program shows you that you
you really don't
okay
so again if
we have small software companies here
and you don't have anything in place
today on security testing this might be
kind of the evolution suggested
evolutionary path
um
and again that's part of a bigger
picture right
starting with responsibility competence
awareness strategy and then
then the testing
so hopefully this could be a blueprint
for anyone who who needs it
um finally i'll leave you with this
um if i mean these are some useful
questions that you can ask yourself as a
software company or you can ask to your
vendors or partners if they are software
companies
first question is you know who is
responsible
for security how does that manifest in
practice
second question you know
do you what kind of security competence
do you have in the organization how do
you support it
third question what threats are you
actually worried about
fourth
how do you protect against those threats
and five what kind of security testing
do you do and how often
thank you
[Applause]
you are questions what exactly it
provides
yep
absolutely
um
yeah so
it allows any organization any project
to
it's for managing a bug bounty program
or multiple bug monthly programs so
you you know you register
and you the first thing is to you know
identify what's the scope you know
what's the scope of my program
what are the assets that i will allow
people to actually
attack or look for vulnerabilities in
you'll decide on you know what are the
awards that i want to have you so you
kind of set up your entire program the
way you want it
and then you again you decide do you
want a private program or a public one
if you are private then you configure
how many people or which people do you
want to have access to this program
and you have all this configuration and
it's a way for you to
um kind of give
other users security researchers hackers
um
a responsible way to
um you know
the rules are clear they know what they
can do and what they can't do
um so it's kind of an yeah nice system
for everything for hackers to to connect
with you and for you to
to find hackers and for to you know
receive reports
triage them analyze them
and then you know assign rewards back
make reports public or not if you want
to do that
so yeah in short it's a bug bounty
management platform
yeah one question
yes
yes absolutely
i mean that's one reason i mentioned it
right
um yeah it's it's good in many different
uh contexts like all of these things
that you see
here um
we often talk about all these things to
our potential or existing customers in
visma right we want to give them a good
impression we tell them how we work with
security and many other things as well
we give them insight into the tools that
we use just like this we talk about the
bug bounty program of course it's a cool
thing to talk about
um so for customers
i think it has a lot of marketing value
i think employees thinks it's cool you
know people receiving reports you know
feeling feeling nervous because you know
my project is going on the bug bounty
program next week or
you know it's like often it's like
drinking from a fire hose the first
couple of days
but most people you know employees think
it's fun customers are usually impressed
by it
and it's also something
that we
you know all of these things
our security program in visma is also
something we kind of highlight
to
companies that we are looking at
joining the visma family as well right
it's one of the
uh superpowers one of the benefits of
joining visma is that well maybe you
were
you know one of these
companies
i have way too many slides
uh
maybe you are one of
these companies
and then you you join this one then you
have this menu the security program that
you can just
onboard and follow and get help with and
you know all the licenses and expertise
and everything you have is there
so
yeah
definitely bug bounty program has a
marketing value in addition to the
security value
yeah any final question
gizmo uses what like six or seven
different types of static code analysis
tools right
how much of that is just because you
have a standardized number one tool and
you're a large company
yeah no excellent so
if we talk about uh
different tools within one category
we
we have one primary tool
and so for sas it's polaris
for dust it's detectify
for software composition analysis it's
snick
um and these are the primary tools those
are the ones that we use in this our
security program those are the tools
that we onboard new companies to
um
the other ones are kind of optional you
know teams or companies can use them if
they want
um
since we have some experience with all
of them i thought i would kind of
mention it i thought that could be
useful
but we do have kind of a primary tool in
all cases
um
yes absolutely for a small software or i
mean for any company i think one in each
category is is enough but
it's important to
have to not just have a sales tool but
then also have a
software composition analysis tool right
so you want to cover all the categories
but
you're fine with only one in each
category um unless like maybe one
exception would be
here right if os dependency check you
know scans your backend and you don't
have anything for your front end well
you want to use retire.js in combination
so that's maybe the exception where you
want to use multiple tools inside of one
category
yeah question but on the
same question don't you find that they
supplement each other or do they pretty
much come up with the same thing
um
it's a good question i think
the best tools will find um
like
you know one tool it's not like one tool
finds this stuff and another tool in the
same category finds this stuff so you
need to use both to find everything like
usually it's an enormous overlap and if
you kind of pick a very good tool
you'll probably cover most of it
so
i mean of course if you have everything
in place if you want to add more tools
to try them out like for instance when i
talked about the pilot here with github
advanced security
um
i asked a team here okay you know you
have been using the these other tools
you have used polaris did github and
security find something new
and they said yes
and so i don't know how much
that is but yeah there was something new
there to
to learn but it's way more important to
have one in each category first before
thinking about multiple tools within one
category i think
okay
looks like we're good uh good to go then
one more question do you have any
experience with seven
semi-graph
sam grip
no no i don't think so
all right thanks everyone
[Applause]
you